when you were on in 2018 you were
talking about the kind of porn that you
like
oh my god this is the greatest i found a
new one
that really is like a victimless crime
where it's like guys either
jerking they're um [ __ ] uh [ __ ]
um pop pocket [ __ ] or like these
real dolls that look really real but
they're teeny tiny
you watch that i it's so great because
they're like yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
poor [ __ ] love but it's a rubber dog
but like there's no woman really there
and so it's amazing it's like everything
i want and nobody gets hurt
after leaving there i you know i didn't
think anything of it
and maybe a cup you know it's not like
i'm looking at porn constantly but
usually like
there's about a week every month just
hormonally where i
become an animal and i must look at you
know look at porn
several times over a couple days and
then um
a new video popped up because i you know
there's only like eight of them it's
very
specific and i
i start watching it and i'm
you know like on lying on my stomach and
looking at my
phone and i have to turn my my glasses
are progressive so i have to like
turn them upside down it's really i have
put tape over the hole because
even a hacker doesn't deserve to have to
see that but i find
this one and i watch it i fast forward a
little bit to the so he's about to come
part and it's got all the elements i
want it's the it's dark
the guy's from the neck down he's on the
side of his shitty bed and the pocket
[ __ ] wedged in there's like a pile of
laundry in the foreground it's just like
makes it real
yeah and as he's coming he says
sarah silverman he says my whole name
twice now my first reaction is
i had a heart attack i thought someone
was like hacking like looking through
at me i rewind it a little and i watch
it again
no in this video he's going oh oh sarah
silverman
sarah silverman then he starts laughing
a little and he goes
that's what you like right by the way i
have a clip of it
and imagine sarah's laying there in her
belly she's taped her eyeglasses upside
down on her nose so she can see what's
going on they don't have to tape them
and then all of a sudden this comes
doesn't happen [ __ ] yeah oh
sarah silverman oh yeah yeah sarah
silverman you like that don't you
i can't believe it i just happened upon
it
somebody made a porn
for me like i've never been so honored
and i couldn't believe it and i am i
mean crazy howard i got a star on the
hollywood walk of fame and this is
this is more of an honor